- Check yourself before our
body pierce your **** skull.
- You think you can pull that trigger
before I blow your personality
out the back of your head?
Then go right ahead,
and test the hypothesis,
and see what happens.
- Alright, I'm gonna
give you a straight up
vampire C-section, like we was
Edward and Bella.
- Edward and Bella.
- Hold up.
You like Twilight?
♪ I don't need ♪
(light jazz music)
- Here is your white wine.
Thank you.
- [Key] You are welcome.
Hey Pete.
Little uh, little thirsty tonight?
- Ah, yeah.
Super thirsty.
- Pete, this is Haraysa.
Haraysa, this is Pete.
- Hey.
- [Key] Haraysa just got back from Africa.
- Oh, Africa.
- Anyways, where was I?
- Oh, the AUC.
- Oh right, so this conflict
is exactly the reason
the African Union Commission
was put in place to address.
- [Haraysa] The organization
of African Unity
certainly wasn't gonna do anything.
- [Key] Exactly, and if
Nkosazana Dlamini-Zuma
wants to do anything about Bangui,
she's certainly being quiet about it.
- The worst part about Bangui
is that no one knows what's going on.
- Oh no, I know.
- I mean look at right
next door, the South Sudan.
- Here's the thing.
Everybody just thinks
that it's like it's the
Lion King over there.
You know?
- Lion King.
- Excuse me?
- It's not the Lion King.
- Exactly.
- I mean what do people think,
a baboon is gonna hold
a lion cub over a rock,
up to the sun while all
the little animals sing?
- Anyway, something else
I wanted to mention is,
they have the manpower because
AMISOM has 25,000 troops
just sitting there in Somalia.
- It's not a three
animated hyena situation.
That doesn't make any sense.
The bad guy isn't Scar over there.
- Um yeah, yeah that's right.
It's not like Scar's the bad guy.
- [Haraysa] Huh, well I mean you know,
the truth is no one knows who to blame.
Because in reality AMISOM
doesn't have that much control.
- They don't.
- [Pete] Like Simba.
Oh, like Simba.
He had no control over well,
he was plucked out from his home,
and went on a whole journey
before he came back and was
just in the middle of a war.
Really had nothing to do with him.
- You know, Pete, I'd be really interested
in hearing your thoughts
on the UN's policies in East Africa.
- Hakuna matata.
- (scoffs) Unbelievable.
- Yes.
My god, that sums it up perfectly.
There's so much work still to be done.
- Yes, that's what I was saying.
- [Haraysa] This been
going on for so many years.
- So many years.
Circle of life.
- Hmm, exactly.
That's really brilliant.
- I dunno about brilliant.
Let's dial it back.
I'm just a man.
- Okay I'm gonna, I'm gonna go get some,
some hors d'oeuvres, okay.
- No need to announce it.
- What are your thoughts
on the Middle East?
- Aladdin.
- Huh.
- Hey guys, Gremlins 2.
I'm telling you this
movie should write itself.
First one was a classic.
This should be pretty straightforward.
Basically all we're doing is maintaining
the integrity of the original picture.
We want to do all the stuff
with the water and the...
Uh, can we help you?
- I'm sorry, let me introduce myself.
Hi y'all.
My name is Star Magic Jackson Jr.
I'm the Hollywood sequel doctor.
So studio just brings me
in to oversee things when
they about to drop a deuce.
So that's why I'm here but don't mind me.
I'm just going to be over here.
Y'all do your thing.
It's your movie.
- Okay.
Let's brainstorm.
Adam.
- If it's gonna take place
in an office building,
I was thinking what if Gizmo
gets wet from a water cooler this time?
- Okay, hold on a second.
I'm sorry, I'm gonna have to step in here.
Just one second sweetheart.
So what's wrong with y'all?
Y'all looking like a bunch of sad sacks.
This is G2 people.
We writin' Gremlins 2.
It should be a party
with pizza and anchovies.
Pineapple.
Just come on, lift up the spirits.
Look, okay, I'm gonna
put a little bit of spice
into the mixture here.
What if we did this?
Everybody here gets to
design they own gremlin.
- I don't see that the
gremlin design is broken.
- It's called brainstorming,
not brain drizzling, sweet pea.
Okay, shut your mouth for a second.
Look, here's the thing,
none of this is final.
- So you mean like what if
there's like a brainy gremlin?
- A brainy gremlin.
- You talking about a
gremlin with glasses,
who could talk and sing
New York, New York?
That's brilliant.
It's in the movie, done.
- Whoa. Whoa, you said
that nothing was final.
- That was before I heard the words brainy
and gremlin in the same sentence together.
It's done.
I love it, it's in the movie.
Next.
- What about a spider gremlin?
- You mean a gremlin with
eight legs and a thorax
just catching pretty ladies in
a web in an office building.
Oh my god.
It's in the movie, I love it.
Next.
- What about a bat gremlin?
- You mean a gremlin with leathery wings?
Just flying around.
Flip flopping, bust through a wall.
Make a perfect bat symbol in the wall.
Get outside getting some wet concrete.
Jump up on a building that's just dry
in place like a gargoyle gremlin.
We are cooking with gas now.
I love it, it's in the movie.
Next.
- Could there be a female gremlin?
- Lipstick, boobies.
*****, you have me a
little gremlin ********.
I love it so much that
it's not only in the movie
but it's definitely in the movie.
There's no backsies on that one.
No penny taxis.
Yes, yes, yes.
In the movie, done.
That's why we need a woman
in the writer's room.
Next.
- I don't know, a googly-eyed gremlin?
- But you do know because you talk
about a gremlin who sole
purpose in this film
is just that he looked stupid as (beep).
Yes, it can be in the movie,
and it is in the movie, done.
Next.
What about you, silver fox?
- Electricity gremlin.
You just said noun and gremlin
like you playing mad libs.
You just like a child.
You have the brain of a child.
You do not have a high
IQ, but you haphazardly
came up with a gremlin
that's just made out of bolts
that are zig-zagging all over the room,
and is done completely in animation.
You a crazy person, and
your idea's in the movie.
Done, next.
- Can we put the Hulkster in it?
- What?
You talking about putting Hulk Hogan,
professional wrestler, turned
actor, turned cultural icon
in the movie where he
break the fourth wall
of the movie he's in by
talking to the audience.
You sir.
Are a raging psychopath.
Don't let this town
take that away from you.
That's it.
I don't even care anymore.
We got the Hulkster in this *****.
So it's done.
I don't have any more time.
So let me just recap right now.
It's brainy gremlin, spider
gremlin, bat gremlin,
lady gremlin, googly-eyed
gremlin, electricity gremlin,
Hulk Hogan's gonna be in the picture.
I'm gonna throw in a gremlin myself.
Vegetable gremlin.
Just write it up.
I'm having so much fun.
- Why not?
Thank you.
It's all gonna be in the actual film.
Now I gotta go put some cowboys
in Back to the Future 3.
Sayonara y'all.
Oops.
(all clapping)
- Now, okay you guys know that none
of that is gonna be in the actual movie.
(exciting synth music)
- Gmail is what I'm on now, that's the uh,
where you got the most
space for attachments.
Anyway.
- [Key] Thank you.
- Feel free to hit me up if
you remember that number.
I notice you ain't write that down.
(car door slams)
****, ****, ****.
That girl was fly, right.
- She a'ight, but did
you see that Liam Neesons
movie with them wolves though?
- The one with them big ***
wolves and Liam Neesons in it?
Liam Neon is my (beep).
- Oh Liam Neesons straight
jacked up them wolves, man.
- Man he (beep)ed them wolves up man.
Shoot, man.
Hey, and don't even get
me started on that one
where they took his daughter.
- (scoffs) Straight Tooken,
starring Liam Neesons.
- Man Liam Neesons is on the phone like,
I have a certain set of skills.
Man don't (beep) with Liam Neesons.
- Don't even try and be
rushing around Liam Neesons.
He'll take your arms and
fracture something. (yells)
- You killin' a man, man.
And then, oh you see
the second one though?
In the second one, the
Russians come after him
and he (beep)ed them all up anyway.
- Tooken 2 starring the
incomparable Liam Neesons.
- That's my (beep).
What about Darkman though?
- No.
- Huh?
- What about Liam Neesons in some Darkman?
- No.
- What about Darkman though?
- When Liam Neesons face
was changing up there?
- Homie was straight face changing.
Now that's just Liam Neesons
acting right there, man.
- Straight up.
I kid you not, Academy award
caliber classic Neesons.
- Come on, seriously.
I mean like Neesons already
need to have a statue.
Liam Neesons ain't got no--
- He ain't got no statue.
He ain't got a statue.
Nope, nope, nope.
- The Oscar goes to Liam Neesons, Darkman.
(beep) face was changing.
How hard is that?
- Word.
- Ain't hard, Dark--
It's not hard at all.
- ****.
- It's stupid, man.
- Oh, oh.
Battleship.
- Oh!
- Battleship, battleship.
Battleship.
- Woo!
- Liam Neesons straight
killed a robot boat.
- Liam Neesons is my shiz-nit.
But you know who I like
as much as Neesons though?
- As much as Neesons?
Who?
- Bruce Willie.
- Oh!
Bruce Willie is my (beep).
- Oh what if they made a movie
with Liam Neesons and Bruce Willie?
- Neesons and Willie?
- Willie and Neesons.
- Harder man, harder.
That what would be my shi- (both yelling)
(explosion)
- What?
What, what, what?
Check yourself before I
body pierce your **** skull.
- You think you can pull that trigger
before I blow your personality
out the back of your head?
Then go right ahead and
test the hypothesis,
and see what happens.
- All right, I'm going
give you a straight up
vampire C-section like we was
Edward and Bella.
- Edward and Bella.
- Hold up.
You like Twilight?
- Yeah, I like Twilight (beep).
- You like Twilight?
- (beep) Twilight's my jam.
- You a Edward (beep) or a Jacob (beep)?
- Answer that (beep) together.
3, 2, 1.
Edward.
- Edward.
- Oh shi.
- Are you (beep)in' with me?
- You either playing some (beep)ed up game
or you were straight up inside my head.
- Yo, and when you said you was
going to blow my personality
out the back of my head,
I'm like that sounds
like some (beep) I would say.
And now this Twilight (beep)?
- That's wavelength (beep).
- So I guess we friends then.
- Oh we best friends now.
We the best of friends.
- BFFs?
- We are BFFs, MF.
♪ When I'm with you ♪
♪ The world stops turning around ♪
♪ Both feet off the ground ♪
♪ When I'm with you ♪
♪ Trumpets start to sound ♪
♪ It's heaven when you're around ♪
- [Key] No, you didn't. (laughing)
That's a great, that's a crazy story, man.
(both laughing)
Woo, too much, boy.
(coughing)
(deeply inhaling, sighs)
(sad piano music)
(gasping) Team Edward.
(police siren chirps)
- Well.
Looks like another gang related killing.
(laughs)
- Surprise, sur-mother(beep)-prise.
("I Just Want To" by Reggie Watts)